the JTF and Sarah were using the site as
a field hospital but armed hostiles
swarmed in now they've got the med staff
as hostages we need them especially
Jessica candle the metrology was running
late find her Center to the base CM was
left we've got a lot of hostels inside
agents they're holding dr. candle and
her staff we need those personnel back
at the base so we can get the medical
wing functional
this is will be wise if you patch me
into the security system I might be able
to find candles location additional
hostile detected
morning additional hostel has detected
that's who we do this for agent go get
him to get to kobes you'll have to pass
by some contaminated areas there used to
be plenty of sick people being treated
there before they got shot so be careful
you'll have to take their crap anymore
you know me
right
morning additional hospitals incoming
morning additional hospitals in coming
gotta drive back
got the medic safely across candle and
all staff accounted for no casualties
we're off to a good start agents wish I
could have had your back out there but I
think we make a hell of a team anyway
when you get back to the base we'll talk
to candle and we'll see what she can do
for us